et bonjour bienvenue pour votre premier
numéro en kiosque de la saison que ce
que votre magazine dédié à la culture
sur saint quentin en yvelines et ses
environs voici le sommaire de ce
mercredi 9 septembre à l'occasion du 50e
anniversaire de la disparition de le
corbusier
nous découvrirons cet architecte c'est
l'un des principaux représentants du
mouvement moderne il a également donné
au béton ses lettres de noblesse louis
nicolas baron de breteuil fut le
responsable des relations officielles
entre louis xiv et les représentants des
puissances étrangères
après la découverte de ses mémoires dans
le château de breteuil une exposition a
été conçue dans le cadre de la
commémoration du tricentenaire de la
mort du roi soleil
la deuxième édition de la biennale
internationale des métiers d'art
contemporain prend ses quartiers au
grand palais à partir de demain jeudi
jean le sable est originaire de
versailles représentera la france cette
artiste peintre décorateur meilleur
ouvrier de france nous expliquera
pourquoi il lui tient à coeur
d'introduire le contemporain dans la
peinture décorative
nous débutons donc par deux
anniversaires celui de la disparition de
louis xiv le 1er septembre 1715 et celui
de la disparition de charles edouard
jeanneret gris dit le corbusier
c'était le 27 août 1965 alors pour sa 12
invités bonsoir leur valette chargée du
label ville d'art et d'histoire au musée
de la ville de saint-quentin musée
installé sur montigny le bretonneux et
bonsoir jean emmanuel charreaux
administrateur du château de breteuil
château de breteuil où une exposition
est proposée
nous y reviendrons dans un instant mais
déjà le corbusier influent dans les
yvelines
son oeuvre emblématique la villa savoye
c'est à poissy fin de construction 1931
on va en voir rapidement des images
alors leur valette
est ce que c'est ce qui illustre le
mieux les techniques de l'architecte la
villa savoye alors dans les yvelines
incontestablement effectivement c'est le
joyau de l'architecturé corbuséenne
c'est la ville a un peu manifeste qui
illustre les fameux 5.2 larchitecture vu
par le corbusier et c'est vrai que c'est
un livre ouvert pour décrypter
le travail de l'architecte sur
l'habitation donc c'est très intéressant
par d'ailleurs des cinq points de
l'architecturé moderne
donc il ya les pilotis les toits
terrasses le plan libre la fenêtre en
bandeau et la façade livre ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus nous expliquer
en quoi ça consiste
mais en fait c'est en cinq points résumé
en cinq points c'est un petit peu sa
révolution qui le propose dans l'
architecture moderne
effectivement c'est enlever en partie ce
rez de chaussée qui étaient le plus
souvent sombre un peu humide pour
surélever le bâtiment d'habitation et
éventuellement laisser de l'espace en
dessous pour un jardin ou pour un garage
voilà c'est déconstruire complètement si
on peut dire le la structure classique
de l'architecturé de la maison
particulier parce que au début c'étaient
les murs qui était porteur est là avec
les les évolutions techniques les
poteaux qui deviennent porteurs laisse
complètement la possibilité d'enlever
les murs et d'avoir un plan complètement
libre à l'intérieur donc un espace à
vivre très différents la fenêtre en
landau c'est très représentatif du
travail sur la lumière qu'a pu faire le
corbusier la lumière devient un matériau
à part entière dans son oeuvre
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très important et qu'on se sent beaucoup
quand on va visiter ces réalisations le
toit terrasse
c'est quelque chose qui reste est
aujourd'hui très très très visible dans
l' architecture contemporaine ans
aujourd'hui nos bâtiments ils sont
beaucoup plus en toit terrasse que en
toi pan donc voilà c'est vraiment les
cinq points qui ont révolutionné l
architecture selon le corbusier
donc la seule réalisation du corbusier
même c'est la villa savoye dans les
yvelines
mais je crois savoir qu'il a une grande
influence sur saint quentin et notamment
sur des bâtiments qui sont juste à côté
de chez nous notamment la bibliothèque
universitaire
oui effectivement il a une grande
influence sur l'architecturé
contemporaine en général et ça n'a pas
échappé aux architectes saint quentinois
de puiser dans les références et dans le
travail qu'a pu faire le corbusier est
effectivement la biu reste quelque chose
assez emblématique à ce niveau là
au delà de la 1000e
universitaires les immeubles perron
également je crois répondent à ces cinq
ans d'architecturé moderne
alors ils répondent pas forcément
directement aux cinq points tels qu'il
les a annoncé mais effectivement c'est
la réinterprétation d'un projet des
meubles villa qui était un projet de le
corbusier dans les années 20 que lui n'a
pas réalisé mais dont dominique perrault
s'est inspiré tout en décalant certaines
choses pour réaliser les immeubles
villas
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres réalisations
également qu'ils s'en inspirent
oui alors pour d'autres réalisations je
dirais que c'est moins une évidence mais
c'est là qu'on voit qu'il a vraiment
profondément marqué cette génération
d'architectes a construit dans les
années 70-80 donc ici aussi enlevé une
nouvelle où les architectes cherche à la
fois se détacher mais en même temps
reviennent aussi vers son influence
puisque en tant qu'élève architectes ils
ont tous eu ce cette révélation c'était
vraiment l'époque où c'était la
modernité absolue d'aller voir les
réalisations de le corbusier donc sur le
travail du béton sur les intérieurs
aussi c'est quelque chose qui reste très
sensible dans leur travail et qu'ils
reconnaissent même s'il essaie de se
détacher de l'influencé corbuséenne pour
d'autres choses sur le travail du béton
d'ailleurs aux arcades de ricardo bofill
je crois qu'il ya un travail particulier
du béton tout à fait alors au ricardo
bofill sur le béton il a vraiment été
dans l'innovation donc dans des
techniques et des technologies qui était
pas celle de l'époque de le corbusier
mais cette idée qu'on peut faire un peu
ce qu'on veut avec le béton que c'est un
matériau noble
vous disiez tout à l'heure que le
corbusier avait donné ses lettres de
noblesse au béton il n'y a pas que lui
les frères perret l'avait déjà fait
avant lui mais c'est vrai que vraiment
c'est la génération d'architectes qui
influence pour ça les contemporains le
béton est un beau matériaux il faut le
redire
aujourd'hui est vraiment ça on leur doit
notamment le corbusier
il ya un travail aussi particulier qui a
été réalisé par rapport à l'
architecture du théâtre qui était un peu
contesté mais
je pense qu'ils s'en inspirent également
qu est-ce qu on retrouve comme élément
alors j'ai plutôt cherché à l'intérieur
je dirais la façade c'est au contraire
le théâtre pour ça et intéressant à la
face est ce au contraire ce qu'on
appelle de l'architecturé postmoderne
qui cherchent plus à réintroduire le
décor et les références classiques
comparé à l' architecture moderne de le
corbusier qui lui prenait vraiment
l'épuration pas de décors vraiment voilà
ça va à l'encontre mais à l'intérieur on
retrouve une sorte de vérité constructif
c'est à dire qu'on lit les volumes à
l'intérieur on sent en fait qu' on est
capable en fait de voir les murs comment
les volumes sont faits il n'y a pas de
camouflage et ça c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui revêt les chauves
souvent chez le corbusier
on va pas camoufler on va pas de décor
et on va pas bariolés on va laisser
s'exprimer l'espace la lumière
l'architecturé et ça c'est très sensible
dans les volumes du couloir et du hall
du théâtre
alors pour les gens qui seraient
intéressés justement partout de cette
architecture moderne mais ça me proche
des journées du patrimoine et je sais
vous voulez préparer activement ce qui
est une thématique particulière pour les
musées de la ville et ces journées alors
effectivement alors on reprend en partie
la thématique nationale qui est
patrimoine du 21e siècle donc pas que
les édifices construits au 21ème siècle
mais aussi qu'est-ce qui fait patrimoine
dans ce qui reste donc plutôt le 20e
siècle
et effectivement nous entre autres ont
fait propose avec les partenaires une
visite du théâtre avec la scène
nationale bien sûr une visite de la
bibliothèque universitaire avec la
bibliothèque universitaire qui guidera
en partie la visite et les immeubles
perron font partie d'un circuit sur
l'habitation contemporaine donc voilà
influence ou pas de le corbusier vous
pouvez venir faire votre propre opinion
lors de ses visites sur les journées du
patrimoine c'est avec plaisir merci pour
l'invitation leur valent êtes vous resté
en plat tant on change de siècle
d'époque avec jean emmanuel chars aux
administrateurs au château de breteuil
car l'autre anniversaire de ce mois de
septembre c'est celui de la disparition
de louis xiv et au château de breteuil
vous présenter une exposition autour de
l'un des hommes de l'ombre du roi soleil
louis nicolas baron de breteuil on en
regarde justement quelques images et on
en parle après des manuscrits retraçant
les mémoires de
la baron de breteil les murs du château
de breteuil en dévoiler deux nouveaux
secrets exposés pour la première fois
ses manuscrits sont aujourd'hui le fil
conducteur de l'exposition consacrée à
cet intime de louis xiv
j'ai la chance d'avoir un ancêtre qui
s'appelait louis nicolas de breteuil qui
était introducteur des ambassadeurs du
roi louis xiv et qui a vu le roi et
travaillé avec le roi tous les jours
entre 1700 et 1715 car son rôle était
d'introduire auprès du roi les
ambassadeurs des pays étrangers
il note en france c'est en 799
à 51 ans que louis nicolas baron de
breteuil obtient la charge d'un
traducteur auprès de louis xiv désormais
chef de protocole il voit le roi
fréquemment et peut lui demander conseil
il avait ce qu'on appelle le pré village
des premières entrées cela signifiait
que le matin pour le réveil du roi
il était là présent avec les médecins et
un certain nombre de privilégiés qui
voyait le roi dans l'intimité et dans
l'exercice de sa de ses fonctions e
louis nicolas de breteuil avait le droit
de demander au roi comment résoudre tel
ou tel problème
responsable des relations officielles de
louis xiv avec les représentants
étrangers
louis nicolas baron de breteuil
accompagnera le roi jusqu'à son dernier
souffle le 1er septembre 10 715 non sans
émotion dans l'écriture de ses mémoires
ce roi partie précipitamment en l'espace
d'une quinzaine de jours de la gangrène
nicolas baron de breteuil introducteur
des ambassadeurs a assisté à la mort de
louis xiv et il a raconté dans ses
mémoires
comment le roi était mort je dirais jour
par jour depuis le 15 août 1715 jusqu'au
1er septembre jour de la mort de louis
xiv ou sont très bien qu'il est
bouleversée de voir comment le roi a mis
en scène sa mort sa mort de roi
chrétien et sa mort de grands souverains
qui a en quelque sorte achevé l'unité de
la france
en marge de cette exposition château de
breteuil la grande galerie héberge les
portraits des contemporains de louis xiv
certains sont signés rigaud célèbre
portraitiste de la période classique
premier numéro de kiosques pour cette
saison il est question de la disparition
du roi soleil jean emmanuel charlot je
disais tout à l'heure que oui nicolas
baron de bretagne et l homme de l'ombre
de louis xiv peut-on dire cela non
l'homme de l'ong peut-être pas tant que
ça puisqu'il était quand même au
quotidien très proches du roi et toute
la cour enviait ce poste d'un traducteur
des ambassadeurs qui permettait à louis
nicolas de rencontrer le roi à son lever
tous les matins en même temps que ses
médecins
donc c'était vraiment un énorme
privilège que vous lui envier n'était
pas tant que ça dans l'ombre du roi il
recueillit en tout cas toutes ces
confidences au quotidien l'émission est
monté en fait autour du fil conducteur
des manuscrite que vous venez de
retrouver au château comment les avez
vous retrouvé
et bien c'est cette manuscrit qui sont 7
très gros livre relié ont été retrouvés
dans les archives du château énormément
de choses dans ses archives familiales
et il y a un petit peu plus de vingt ans
elles ont été étudiées et c'est cet
ouvrage sont ressortis des archives et
vine le vert qui est commissaire général
de l'exposition actuelle a beaucoup
travaillé sur ces 7 manuscrits et on a
extrait certains
passages croustillants alors justement
je crois que ces manuscrits sont donc
riches en enseignement et en anecdotes
est-ce que vous en auriez une ou deux à
nous faire partager
alors il ya deux deux passages en
particulier que nous montrons dans
l'exposition
les deux livres sont ouvert ses pages là
le premier dans l'ordre chronologique
c'est le récit de la nuit de noces du
duc de bourgogne petit fils de louis xiv
la ligue de bourgogne s'est mariée très
jeune sa femme et qui est encore plus
jeune que lui il a donc dû attendre deux
ans je crois avant de consommer son
mariage donc quand le jour et est enfin
arrivé et bien louis nicolas raconte
dans ses mémoires qu'il a eu l'honneur
de tenir le chandelier pour mener le duc
de bourgogne à la chambre de madame la
duchesse de bourgogne et il décrit la
tenue du duc de bourgogne qui avait la
tête fort frisé donc sa plus belle
perruque ici on peut comporter comme ça
une très jolie robe de chambre et qu'il
était plein d'entrain pour aller
rejoindre le champ de bataille c'est
comme ça qu'il décrit la chambre à
coucher du sial donc une dernière
question alors valette pour le musée de
la ville ont parlé avec vous de l'
influence de le corbusier sur la
réalisation de 50 ans olivier
l'agglomération nouvelle louis xiv roi
bâtisseur à at il aussi était une source
d'inspiration pour nos architectes louis
xiv en lui-même je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas ville nouvelle de l'époque
c'est versailles donc forcément il ya un
écho qui est assez intéressant sur le
fait d'y implanter ici lui nouvelle à
proximité et même en partie dans ce qui
faisait partie du domaine et du grand
parc de versailles donc oui d'une ville
nouvelle à l'autre on pourrait dire n'y
a qu'un pas alors l'exposition château
de breteuil c'est jusqu'au 28 novembre
d'autres éléments de la programmation à
mettre en avant pour conclure peut-être
et bien pour le mois qui arrive nous
avons comme tous les samedis et
dimanches de septembre et d'octobre des
contes de perrault à 4h30 tous les
après-midi ce sera tous les jours
pendant les vacances scolaires de la
toussaint pour les amateurs de théâtre
il ya ce dimanche
le petit chaperon rouge qui sera jouée
par la troupe du crâne et puis pour les
j'ai envie de patrimoine ou bien nous
aussi bien sûr nous nous avons au public
qui nous espérons avoir beaucoup plus de
monde que les autres jours et ces
personnes pourront découvrir dans le
parc de breteuil toutes les statues que
nous avons rénové récemment c'est un
gros gros travail de restauration mais
maintenant les statuts qui sont toutes
du xviiie sont absolument superbes
restaurer alors merci à vous deux et
concernant la disparition de louis xiv
vous pourrez retrouver dès le 27 octobre
au château de versailles une exposition
de l'auto petits aux funérailles du roi
soleil à saint denis
elle fourmille de détails rappelons que
cet événement constitue un tournant
historique
c'est l'achèvement du règne le plus long
de la monarchie française 72 ans mieux
que la reine d'angleterre qui fête
aujourd'hui ses soixante trois années
sur le trône britannique
qu'est-ce que se poursuit maintenant
avec une autre exposition au salon des
révélations et autour d' c'est la
deuxième édition de la biennale
internationale des métiers d'art
contemporain qui se tiendra donc au
grand palais à partir de demain et
jusqu'au 13 septembre
elle réunira plus de 300 créateurs de 17
pays la france sera représentée par le
versaillais jean sable et que vous voyez
à l'image artistes décorateurs il eu
meilleur ouvrier de france et fondateur
de l'école sablé école de peinture
décorative et trompe l'oeil
la peinture décorative introduite en
france par françois 1er je le rappelle
jean sablé a fait le soin pour le salon
des révélations d'exposer cinq toiles
contemporaines
on écoute l'objectif c'est vraiment de
réveiller un peu les consciences
beaucoup de métier on se sont se sont
modernisées jusqu'à la peinture
décorative
c'est un petit peu un petit peu endormi
et voilà j'attends un petit peu le
réveil des consciences et je crois qu'on
peut vraiment traduire la peinture
décorative
dans le contemporain on peut on peut
modifier ou du moins changer les aspect
décoratif esthétique de versailles
sans renier à versailles sans renier ses
décors mais vraiment en les faisant
vivre au 21e siècle et nous partons
maintenant pour montigny le bretonneux
où les élèves du conservatoire des arts
se prépare au festival d'art mural fait
le mur qui débute demain jeudi dans la
nièvre
un festival autour des techniques du
trompe l'oeil nous les avons rencontrés
avant leur départ les images de patrick
jacques de dixmude très fier d'être le
seul chantier école les élèves du cours
de trompe l'oeil du conservatoire des
arts de montigny participeront à la
deuxième édition du festival d'art mural
fait le mur du 10 au 14 septembre dans
la nièvre
c'est une expérience pour nous pour
cours de trompe l'oeil et surtout c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer des vrais
professionnels en chantier dans une
ambiance de chantier on va tous
s'entraider aussi pour marouflé ses
grandes toiles immenses sur les panneaux
parce qu'il faut de la main d'oeuvre
d'expérience aussi donc c'était vraiment
l'occasion de de faire un cours et à
mettre les élèves dans le temps le bain
complètement
après avoir conçu la maquette cet été
les élèves confirmés ou novices
s'affairent depuis une semaine matin et
soir sur leurs fresques de 27 m²
initialement vierge en respectant
scrupuleusement la technique du trompe
l'oeil le trompe l'oeil on va dire c'est
à cheval entre le bâtiment la peinture
bâtiment et
la peinture artistique dans le sens où
on est toujours sur des surfaces
verticales et des contraintes de
perspective donc forcément de proportion
de mesures de compromis lh2 on triche
avec la perspective entre riches avec la
lumière donc c'est vraiment assez
technique art mural qui revient à la
mode sur les façades de nos grandes
villes le trompe-l'oeil attire dans son
cours de plus en plus de curieux de tous
les âges à montigny qui espèrent bien
rafler un prix au festival à partir de
jeudi
je reçois à présent rachat le boulanger
dumas présidente du fils du festival
orphée pardon rond soit dans le soir un
festival de théâtre européen original
car didier aux personnes en situation de
handicap ou plutôt ce sont les personnes
en situation de handicap que l'on
retrouvera sur scène
alors d'où vient cette idée pourquoi
cette initiative bon cette initiative je
vais être très rapide qui a été créée
dans le cadre de l'année européenne du
handicap qui était en 2003 et pour
lequel nous avions postulé avec l'idée
d'un beau projet de festival européen
pour travailler sur la promotion des
artistes des artistes professionnels en
situation de handicap je préfère ce
terme car ce sont certes des personnes
handicapées quel que soit le handicap
mais qui sont avant tout des artistes
professionnels dans tous les domaines de
ce que l'on appelle le spectacle vivant
c'est à dire le théâtre la danse la
musique le mime le cirque et cetera
donc ce week-end débute la 13e édition
ça veut dire que cela marche
quel est le bilan des précédentes c'est
un bon bilan parce que effectivement
quand on s'est lancé dans l'aventuré on
connaissait pas l'accueil que nous
recevrons que nous oui que nous
recevrons nous recevrions pardon et
effectivement il y a eu un accueil
formidable parce qu'on a trouvé des
compagnies à travers l'europe qui était
de d'immenses qualités que ce soit des
britanniques des espagnols des italiens
du pays bas vous savez qu'on a invité
depuis 2003 près de cinquante sept
compères compagnies européennes qui
viennent et puis en même temps on a
donné maintenant un élargissement à
l'international
puisqu'on a invité aussi des musiciens
sénégalais des danseurs brésiliens des
congolais est donc maintenant on peut
dire que le festival orphée à cette
caractéristique qui a dépassé l'europe
et qui maintenant est internationale
voilà est bon c'est parce que pourquoi
parce qu'on a choisi d très beau
spectacle et que le public a été au
rendez-vous d'année en année il s'est
accru voilà c'est comme ça que ça marche
alors justement ce public à qui
s'adresse-t-il y est il un public
spécifique non il n'y a pas de public
spécifique nous avons nous accueillons
effectivement beaucoup de personnes qui
elles sont en situation de handicap qui
ne sont pas des artistes mais qui aiment
l'art et qui sont heureuses parce que
elle considère que ce festival aurait un
peu destinée quelque part quelque fois
c'est difficile pour certains d'aller
des représentations à shakespeare par
exemple ou autre alors que dans la
programmation d'orphée il et trouvent
leur marché mais le festival orphée
destinée absolument à tous les publics
et je suis très contente car le public
lambda celui qu'on appelle le public
lambda
eh bien rien de plus en plus nombreux
donc en fait on a à la fois la mixité
sur scène puisque nos compagnies sont
souvent composés d'artistes valide
est ce qu'on appelle non valides et dans
la salle on retrouve la même mixité
alors pour nous c'est un honneur parce
que c'est ça le but d' orphée c'est de
mixer les populations x et les artistes
et puis s'adresser à tous les publics
c'est à dire que dans une programmation
diversifiée nous avons à la fois des
spectacles qui sont pour des enfants par
des ados pour des adultes des spectacles
qui sont faits pour lui tous les publics
je crois que c'est un peu la vocation
leur fait et c'est peut-être pour ça que
ça marche c'est 2 d'avoir pu mais les
mêlées mais les mêlées et moi c'est un
peu comme ça que j'aime la vie c'est
l'état d'esprit
alors pour mixer ces publics 7 théâtre
participe c'est théâtre des yvelines
commencer la voir le programme
alors le programme est bien le programme
a débuté à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
samedi prochain avec une chorégraphie
justement franco-grecque absolument avec
une mixité formidable puisque ya trois
identités ya la grèce y à villiers le
bel il ya beaucoup de danseurs de
villiers le
elles qui sont exceptionnels c'est très
multiraciale et des quatre danseurs
affirme moteurs cérébraux qui sont assez
exceptionnelles donc ça c'est à
saint-arnoult le 12 septembre
nous débutons après le mardi 22
septembre au théâtre montansier avec
l'empereur c'est moi orio c'est ça
traite de l'autisme à nouveau un ami
âmes à ce fameux spectacle que j'ai
programmé à nouveau le 26 à versailles
au théâtre montansier parce que le
public de saint-arnoult vient pas
forcément à versailles
je crois que ce spectacle va être mon
spectacle c'est très étonnant hein
après nous avons face de cuillère quête
à une très jolie
c'est du théâtre le 29 septembre cette
enseigne qui est la sclérose en plaques
mise en scène le 30 septembre après le 2
octobre à fontenay le fleury avec les
amours inutile d'après maupassant un
spectacle est joué par des sourds et par
des comédiens vague l'aide en même temps
un très beau ça très très beau le 6
octobre sept à marly-le-roi avec une
dans la peau de cyrano qui est un gros
succès et puis après nous avons le 11
octobre au chapiteau méli mélo à
versailles avec mon amour ma béquille ma
bataille
après nous avons à la royale factory à
versailles surtout jour avec un artiste
sourds très comique et puis nous
terminerons le 17 octobre à verneuil qui
est une nouvelle commune qui s'est
associé au festival orphée avec percu
dia alors et des artistes autistes
musiciens alors qui eux vous retrouvez
ne vous arrêtez pas le programme complet
sur orphée festival.com merci je vous
rappelle boulanger d'humains une autre
information la ville de montigny le
bretonneux lance sa troisième édition du
tremplin musical the chase
organisée en partenariat avec
l'interface hausse de l'ue vs qu
fédération fédération pardon des
associations étudiantes alors si vous
êtes un groupe yvelinois au répertoire
original
envoyez votre fichier vidéo avant le 15
octobre sur sm a hâte montini 78 point
fr cinq groupes seront retenus pour la
soirée du 14 novembre à montigny jury et
public éliront le grand gagnant
invité par la suite a réalisé la
première partie d'un
connu pour les présélections et
sélection finale les critères retenus
sont les mêmes et ses marques
isaac hauts responsables du secteur de
musiques amplifiées de montigny et
membre du jury qui nous les donne les
critères c'est la qualité de la
structure du morceau la qualité des
arrangements la qualité de
l'interprétation du chant et aussi le
rapport au public chaque juré à une
feuille avec ses critères et va donc
notée sur chacun de ces critères et
après on fait la moyenne et ça donne une
note
c'est un tremplin c'est le cas de le
dire pour être un peu plus crédibles
dans leurs démarches auprès
deux tourneurs de boîte de production et
avant de se quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas le dimanche 13
septembre à 11 heures à l'abbaye de port
royal des champs pour un concert lecture
valdaine la manifestation ouvrira le
festival de musique ile-de-france et le
25 septembre un peu plus tard
l'ouverture de la saison de la batterie
à guyancourt avec un concert du groupe
electro deluxe réservations toujours
possible sur la plateforme que ce que
point est-ce qu y point fr enfin le 9 9
octobre à plaisir malik bentalha
l'humoriste sera sur la scène de
l'espace coluche pour son one man show
malik bentalha se la raconte
enfin du kiosque pour cette semaine
émission à revoir sur notre site
internet
je vous retrouve mercredi prochain le
mercredi 16 septembre aux mêmes horaires
pour un nouveau point sur l'actualité
culture